[Applauso]
La globalizzazione può sembrare un
fenomeno moderno ma non lo è il
commercio globale c'è sempre stato Ok
5000 anni fa nell'età della pietra si
usavano in Europa strumenti fatti con
pietre
asiatiche le monete romane erano fatte
d'oro africano nel
17o gli europei andavano pazzi per
prodotti fatti
d'Avorio finché un giorno il prezzo si
moltiplicò senza
spiegazione anni dopo abbiamo capito che
erano stati uccisi così tanti elefanti
africani che non c'erano più esemplari
adulti le zanne erano sempre più piccole
ma era già troppo tardi l'industria
dell'avorio era già crollata ora a quei
tempi si capisce che le informazioni su
la provenienza delle materie prime
avrebbe messo tanto tempo a raggiungere
i mercati Anzi forse era impossibile
sapere di dove venivano le cose e si
penserebbe anche che oggi sarebbe molto
più facile CAP di dove vengono le cose e
ince non è il caso n 2011 questa Fabrica
di General Motors in Louisiana Chiuse il
24 di Marzo
2011 data Chia
perché chiusero perché mancava un
componente un sensore d'ossigeno
che Alim cioè l'ossigeno alimenta i
motori a benzina senza sensori niente
motori Il problema è che è chiuse perché
il fornitore di più di metà dei sensori
d'ossigeno del mondo era in Giappone ed
era stato distrutto due settimane prima
dallo tsunami del 2011 tohoku Tsunami e
non l'hanno saputo hanno messo due
settimane per scoprire che le che i
componenti non c'erano più per chiudere
la fabbrica aspettando rifornimenti E
questa fabbrica non non riaprì
mai nel l'anno prossimo il
2012 alcune parti di New York quelle
parti che vedete che sono buie sono
state inondate da più di 5 m d'acqua di
mare da un uragano questo uragano ha
anche distrutto le pompe che collegano
la città alle pipeline da Houston che l'
alimentano di carburante senza
carburante a New York non funzionano le
ambulanze non si riparano le
infrastrutture non si scaldano le case 8
giorni la città ci ha messo per capire
che l'uragano aveva distrutto le pompe
che la collegavano a Houston 8 giorni
durante i quali questa città di 20
milioni era senza
carburante Vabbè non sono anni ma 8
giorni poi Nel 2020 non mi devo
ricordare cosa è successo quanto tempo
ci hanno messo gli ospedali per ottenere
scorte d'emergenza mesi a volte durante
la pandemia quando i loro fornitori
chiaramente non erano più disponibili
Com'è possibile che oggigiorno ci
vogliono settimane o mese per capire di
dove vengono i prodotti con tutti i
nostri mezzi tecnologici ipers
sofisticati allora mi sono mi sono
veramente interessato a questo problema
cosa rende le supply chain così opache
nel 2010 stavo facendo ricerca in India
e sono andato a intervistare dei
produttori di cotone produttori che
contavano sul cotone sulla vendita
annuale di cotone per la loro
vita e più volte vendevano tutto al
primo commerciante che passava Perché
Perché non sapevano se ce ne sarebbe
passato un altro o se il secondo avrebbe
dato un miglior
prezzo non sapendo questo vendevano
tutto subito più presto possibile erano
completamente sconnessi dal commercio
globale non conoscevano i prezzi del
mercato e non sapevano dove andavano a
finire le loro
merce quell'anno migliaia di produttori
di cotone indiani Hanno smesso di
produrre cotone perché non ci
guadagnavano abbastanza e sono andati a
produrre altre cose il prezzo del cotone
del 2010 è raddoppiato che ha ha reso
l'industria intera del tessile
completamente instabile Ecco cosa
succede con queste queste mancanze di
visibilità nelle supply chain Allora io
a quei tempi stavo facendo ricerca su
nuovi media al MIT a Boston e mi sono
chiesto se c'era modo con queste questi
queste nuove tecnologie chei uscivano di
connettere le supply chain di renderle
più trasparenti per poi risolvere non
solo il problema delle interruzioni ma
anche il problema di chi non si faceva
pagare abbastanza delle supp che non
erano etiche E così ho cominciato a
lavorare con alcune grandi aziende per
mappare le loro supply chain per capire
cosa mancava nei loro sistemi di
gestione e quello che ho scoperto è
abbastanza sconvolgente perché una
supply chain moderna per una
multinazionale comprende decine di
migliaia di fornitori su 5 10 15 livelli
diversi ognuno compreso la
multinazionale conosce solo i suoi
clienti diretti e i suoi fornitori
diretti qualche
centinaia nessuno aveva una visione
globale della supply chain e così è
ovvio che se ci succedeva qualcosa
cinque o sei livelli indietro ci
volevano giorni o settimane perché le
notizie arrivino al mercato finale po
un'altra illustrazione della complessità
Questa è la supply chain del microfono
dentro al vostro cellulare non del
cellulare del microfono il microfono
dentro al vostro cellulare comprende sei
o sette livelli di transazioni 200
componenti diversi e questo solo nel
microfono cioè pensate quanto è
complesso il cellulare quanto è
complesso la supply chain dell'azienda
che fornisce cellulari o dell'Industria
intera cioè quasi inimmaginabile per
fortuna per fortuna in quel momento
c'era anche nuove tecnologie che stavano
uscendo che permettevano di gestire
questo tipo di complessità i social
network i social network collegano
centinaia di milioni di persone in tempo
reale persone che non si sarebbero mai
conosciute senza questa tecnologia poi
se ci pensate la supply chain è un
social network c'è una rete di
connessione tranne che non è visibile ma
ci connette tutti anzi è il social
network più grande e più complesso del
mondo
intero così che lo vedo io eh E così
Source Map è nata cioè la mia startup
era l'applicazione della tecnologia dei
social network alla problematica della
supply chain Come rendere le supply
chain trasparenti tramite la tecnologia
e la logica dei social network e ora vi
racconto Come'è stata realizzata
eh nel
2013 sono usciti alcuni modelli
climatici molto preoccupanti per
l'industria del cioccolato e dunque
molto preoccupanti per tutti
noi questi modelli mostravano che la la
parte del mondo che produce la metà del
cacao tra Costa d'Avorio e Ghana la
parte verde che vedete qui sulla
carta potenzialmente sparirebbe sarebbe
sparita per via del cambiamento
climatico vedete quanto verde c'è
rimasto nel
2050 così l'industria si è preoccupata
il più grande uno dei più grandi
produttori di cioccolato ci ha
contattati per vedere se potevamo
mettere in moto sourcemap per creare
questo social network per connettere
produttori di cacao con Brand globali e
così così è partito come è funzionato è
funzionato che i nostri clienti i loro
acquisti buyer in Europa negli Stati
Uniti hanno invitato i loro fornitori su
sourcemap questi sarebbero i grandi
commercianti di cacao globale e questi
hanno invitato i loro fornitori gli
esportatori nei paesi Da dove viene il
cacao a registrarsi su sourcemap e
questi hanno invitato le cooperative le
aziende più vicine ai produttori a
registrarsi Così nel giro di poche
settimane siamo riusciti a
mappare la catena di di
approvvigionamento di questa grande
azienda di cioccolato per la prima volta
già qualcosa poi gli impiegati di queste
cooperative di queste aziende in tutta
la regione sono andati sui terr
fisicamente con la prima generazione di
smartphone a raccogliere informazioni di
base non solo sulla produttività dei
campi ma anche sulle condizioni sociali
Perché in fondo c'era questa
preoccupazione che se il cacao non
andava più sarebbero andati a produrre
altre cose allora per capire un po' per
avere un quadro intero sulle condizioni
ambientali sociali e di produttività dei
campi sono arrivati fino a mappare tutte
le proprio tutte le superfici perché
produce cacao pensate che siamo arrivati
fino ai villaggi dentro ai villaggi
capire le scuole le infrastruttura di
l'elettricità le banche medicina proprio
a ispezionare ogni cosa per capire se o
no L'industria del cacao poteva contare
sulla produzione di cacao per gli anni
per per i decenni a venire Cioè questo è
stato ha cambiato l'industria
onestamente Perché dal dall'essere
completamente
nel buio e non capire le condizioni a
questa connessione poi pensate che non
era che vedevano le condizioni alcuni
campi alcune aziende agricole le
vedevano su centinaia di migliaia di
aziende agricole diverse su tutto il
territorio in tempo reale Sconvolgente
Poi hanno scoperto tante cose e ci
lavorano
ancora questo ponte che è stato creato
tra l'altro hanno viaggiato migliaia di
chilometri e hanno attraversato le
divisioni più più fondament mentali
socioeconomiche culturali tecnologiche
del mondo così su una piattaforma ora
oggi sourcemap lavoriamo con Come avete
sentito con con i più grandi gruppi le
più grandi aziende del mondo Non solo
nell'alimentare ma anche nella medicina
nell' bigliamento nel lusso automobili
elettronica ci sono milioni di fornitori
oggi che usano la stessa piattaforma per
scambiare dati e per rendere le supply
chain più trasparenti più etiche ma non
è sempre stato facile È vero che alcuni
attori dentro le supply chain traggono
un certo beneficio dal fatto che le
supply rimangano
opache vi racconto un'altra storia nel
ora nel 19 Quando il governo brasiliano
addirittura incoraggiava la
deforestazione per aprire nuovi terreni
per allevamenti per la pelle soprattutto
e uno dei nostri clienti un gran
produttore di scarpe ha chiesto di usare
Source Map per mappare il cuoio fino
alle origini per essere sicuri di non
essere coinvolti in questa
deforestazione e così è come nel cacao i
produttori hanno invitato le fabbriche
di scarpe che hanno che si sono
registrate su Source Map le fabbriche
hanno invitato le concerie che si sono
registrate le concerie hanno invitato i
macelli i macelli hanno evitato gli
allevamenti e così nel giro di poche
settimane abbiamo mappato l'industri
industria globale del cuoio una buona
parte
dell'Industria globale del cuoio adesso
zoomi perché la tecnologia aveva fatto
dei passi enormi dei Bondi da gigante
nel frattempo e avevamo accesso anche a
immagini satellitari che ci mostravano
la deforestazione e gli incendi in tempo
reale e così abbiamo
potuto sovrapporre la supply chain dei
nostri clienti con queste immagini degli
incendi che vedete le zone rosse sulla
mappa e così i nostri clienti Hanno
scoperto che Infatti la loro supply
chain Si stava muovendo verso nord in
amazonia verso nord Dove stavano
bruciando attivamente di maniera Cioè in
tempo reale le foreste e hanno fatto la
cosa più radicale che si possa
fare hanno annunciato un boicottaggio
del cuoio brasiliano finché i fornitori
non possano mostrare che era stato
prodotto senza deforestazione l'hanno
annunciato la mattina del 29 di
Agosto
entro poche ore il governo brasiliano è
stato costretto a mettere una moratoria
su sugli
incendi la trasparenza delle supply
chain sta riscrivendo le leggi della
globalizzazione del Commercio
globale adesso vedrete Quest'anno l'anno
prossimo tutta una nuova generazione di
leggi che richiedono che esono che la
contabilità come si si direbbe in
inglese ma la la presa in coscienza
delle pratiche della supply chain intera
dalla parte di tutti i grandi gruppi
europei e nordamericani su tutti questi
temi sociali e ambientali Che vuol dire
che i Brand non vogliono comprare cose
prodotte in condizioni terribili perché
sanno che non ci possono contare sopra
ma anche i governi non lo vogliono
perché sono in concorrenza con paesi
dove gli standard sono completamente
diversi Allora vogliono che gli standard
siano gli stessi e tutte queste leggi
sono possibili solo grazie a questa
nuova tecnologia della mappatura delle
supply
chain ora per finire c'è un'ultima
storia
ma Source l'ho creata per rendere le
supply chain più trasparenti perché
siano più etiche non per leggi non
per rischi da da
prevenire perché fondamentalmente la
trasparenza deve creare una nuova
relazione di fiducia tra produttori
industria Industria e consumatori nel
2021 un grande produttore di orologi di
lusso ha cominciato a mappare la sua
supply chain consorce Map per capire le
condizioni di lavoro ad ogni fase ad
ogni livello della supply chain fino
alle miniere d'oro e così una volta
mappata verificata tutta la supply chain
nel 22 Hanno lanciato il primo orologio
di lusso completamente tracciabile al
pubblico con le informazioni aperte a
tutti per verificare le condizioni in
cui sono stati prodotti gli orologi
orologio che si è venduto ogni esemplare
in poche
settimane e così se vi lascio una cosa
una lezione qui è che io sono partito
pensando che c'era del bene e del male
nelle supply chain ma invece se smap
esiste è che tutti vogliono sapere le
condizioni in cui sono stati prodotti La
cosa che mi affascina ancora è che la
globalizzazione c'è da sempre ma è solo
adesso che siamo in grado di capirla di
misurarla non mancava la volontà
mancavano i dati mancavano gli strumenti
e adesso che possiamo realmente mappare
le supply chain vuol dire che possiamo
coinvolgere tutti gli attori non solo
nella supply chain Ma nell'innovazione
in questa economia della conoscenza
della cui beneficiamo tutti cioè è è il
primo momento In quale possiamo
veramente sfruttare il potenziale
innovativo di tutti quelli che
partecipano nella nostra vita anche a
qualsiasi la distanza Questa è una
bellissima cosa cioè la mappatura delle
supply chain rivela la nostra
connessione umana a tutte le persone del
mondo che vuol dire che finalmente
possiamo coinvolgere tutti noi
nell'innovazione delle risorse e così
questa trasparenza questa connessione
umana è quella che permetterà di avere
veramente un'economia globale etica e
sostenibile